well let's bring in ed dave we should we
he is uh the leader of the liberal
democrats it's great to see you thanks
for joining us on the programme as
always did you applaud the prime
minister yesterday
no i didn't and the reason is that um i
called his resignation uh some months
ago
and i think he's been a very poor prime
minister
breaking the law but most importantly
failing to help millions of families and
pensioners so it would have been
hypocritical to applaud and i found it a
little bit
weird if i'm honest with you that all
these conservative mps who'd just knifed
boris johnson in the back were now
applauding him and it seemed it seemed
quite surreal to me
um but we weren't going to be
hypocritical i left that to the
conservatives
what did you make of the fact that um
theresa may didn't stand up what she did
eventually but she certainly didn't
applaud was that a bit chillish
i think she was being true to what she
thought i don't think she's ever rated
boris johnson as a good prime minister
um and uh in that in that regard i agree
with her i think boris johnson has been
very bad for the country
uh and i think he's divided the country
i think he
has got a dreadful record on so many
things particularly economy
um and with inflation going through the
roof and the cost of living crisis
like nothing we've seen for generations
i think he bears a heavy responsibility
for the the pain that many families are
feeling now
um
and then there were two head-to-head uh
debates uh coming up four hours is a
fortnight today um finally got that over
the line what do you want to hear from
those debates
well i'd like to hear a real plan a plan
for our economy but in particular a plan
for the millions of
families and pensioners who are facing a
financial catastrophe
this autumn already we know and you and
i have discussed this before okay
haven't we um so many people are
struggling out there with food bills
filling their
cars worried about their heating bills
this winter and we know it's going to
get worse we saw inflation going up
again this month
and we know that um the energy price cap
is going to go up hundreds of pounds
again
in the autumn and it's the big elephant
in the room and i've been shocked up
until now to be honest in the tory
leadership cabinet debates that it's
like the elephant in the room this is a
huge iceberg coming to hit people this
catastrophe
just uh over horizon
and none of them seem to be addressing
that problem they seem to be talking
about you know how to help better off
people wealthy people
tory party members they're not talking
about how to help the tens of millions
of families and pensioners who are
desperately worried at the moment
why would somebody want to be a prime
minister at the moment to try to
navigate us through this
catastrophe well
if you're a patriot and you want to help
our country
in an hour of crisis then you should
stand up
uh and as a liberal democrat i believe
that
we have policies that could help the
country at the moment and i mean i've
been advocating them across the country
we've won three by-elections in the last
year against the conservatives in their
heartlands because we've been arguing
for real help for families and
pensioners faced with this cost-living
emergency we've talked for example
about a cut-in vat
that would both reduce inflation it
would help business on the high street
but it in particular it would deliver a
600 pound tax cut to families and
pensioners and you know that's a sort of
practical policy
that is right for the moment that
liberal democrats have been putting
forward and we've been putting it full
responsibility because i was the first
politician to talk about a windfall tax
to get the money from the oil and gas
companies who are making so much money
at the moment and give it back to people
who are struggling and so um i want to
hear
positive policies like little democrats
have been putting forward and you know
you ask about
who do you want to run the country well
i think people do if they want to help
people and if they're a patriot
okay um it's great to see you and as
always come in and see us um soon thank
you very much indeed thank you thank you